taylor swift is a bridesmaid  [Music]  the 27 year old singer has kept a low  profile since releasing her new single  last week  but on saturday taylor helped longtime  bestie abigail anderson say i do at  martha's vineyard in massachusetts  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  taylor stunned in a deep maroon halter  gown her hair down and curled pairing  the look with her signature bold red lip  while the bride-to-be stunned in an  ivory wedding dress with lace detailing  her hair swept into an updo  taylor was the best bridesmaid to have  even holding abigail's train as she  entered the church  that is the best kind of friendship you  can have  [Music]